Tyra: PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
TOCCARA'S SEXY FULL FIGURE
MADE HER A STAR.
Toccara: I LOVE
TO BE IN THE SPOTLIGHT.
I LIKE TO BE
THE CENTER OF ATTENTION.
Tyra: KELLE RECEIVED HARSH
CRITICISM FROM THE JUDGES.
Janice: IT'S KIND OF
LOOKING LIKE BREAST EXAM TO ME.
Tyra: AND ALTHOUGH
JENNIPHER SHOWED
A CRITICAL ERROR
IN JUDGMENT...
Janice: ARE YOU
KIDDING ME?
Tyra: IT WAS KRISTI'S
INSECURITY
THAT THE JUDGES
COULDN'T OVERLOOK.
TEN GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED
TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
Jennipher: AND THEY
THOUGHT I HAD NO PERSONALITY.
Eva: GIRL,
I WOULDN'T HAVE--I JUST--
YEAH, YOU SHOULD HAVE ASKED ME
BEFORE YOU WENT.
Jennipher: THE LAST JUDGING
DIDN'T GO SO WELL.
Janice: THAT'S LIKE
LICENSE TO GET FIRED,
PLAYING THAT KIND OF A JOKE
ON A RUNWAY.
Jennipher: THE WHOLE
WRITING ON THE BUTT THING,
THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT I WOULD DO.
I'M TRYING TO JOKE AROUND MORE,
BUT...
Eva: TYRA IS
A VERY CLASSY LADY.
SHE DOES NOT LIKE
THAT TYPE OF STUFF.
THAT'S NOT
CLASSY.
AND JANICE
DIDN'T LIKE IT,
AND I'M GONNA
TELL YOU,
IF JANICE DON'T LIKE IT,
IT AIN'T GOOD.
FOUL BALL.
Ann: I HAVEN'T BEEN
DOING WELL,
BUT TYRA AND NIGEL
LOVED MY PHOTO
FOR THE LEE JEANS AD.
Tyra: WOW, ANN!
Ann: SO THAT WAS GOOD
BECAUSE THEY FINALLY SAID TO ME
NOW WE SEE THAT, LIKE,
WHY YOU'RE HERE.
IF I CAN
GET MYSELF TOGETHER,
I THINK IT'LL
KEEP GETTING BETTER.
Kelle: I DEFINITELY DIDN'T
GET THIS FAR IN THE COMPETITION
FOR HAVING, LIKE,
AMAZING PHOTOGRAPHS,
THAT'S FOR DAMN SURE,
BUT I'M TRYING TO KEEP IN MIND
THAT, YOU KNOW, THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT JUST
CAN COME WITH PRACTICE.
Toccara: LIKE MAMA'S
BEEN MAKING ME MAD A LOT LATELY,
AND THEN I CALLED HER AND I
TOLD HER ABOUT IT AND SHE'S ALL,
"WELL, I'M DEPRESSED
RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T WANNA TALK
ABOUT IT,"
YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M SAYIN'?
AND IT WAS LIKE...
Man: She didn't mean
no harm.
Toccara: I'M PROUD
OF WHO I AM,
AND I'M PROUD
OF WHERE I COME FROM.
I KIND OF HAD TO BE
TOUGH ALL MY LIFE.
MY MOM AND MY FATHER--
THEY HAD PROBLEMS,
AND SO I'VE KIND OF
BEEN THE MAMA.
I HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT I'M OKAY.
I CAN'T RELY ON
ANYBODY BUT ME.
Yaya: TYRA MAIL.
Toccara: WE'RE
READIN' IT NOW.
Norelle: "NEW YORK PRETZELS
AREN'T THE ONLY THINGS
"THAT ARE
TWISTED."
Toccara: "TWISTED."
THAT'S GOOD.
THE TYRA MAIL SAYS THAT PRETZELS
ARE NOT THE ONLY THINGS
THAT CAN BEND.
GO UPSTAIRS
AND SAAVAS IS THERE.
Saavas: I'M GETTING
WARMED UP FOR YOU.
Amanda: SAAVAS IS
OUR PERSONAL TRAINER.
I THINK SAAVAS' PURPOSE
IS TO,
LIKE, GET US INTO, LIKE,
IDEAL MODEL SHAPE.
Saavas: YOGA
FOR THE DAY.
ALL RIGHT,
LET'S GET STARTED.
AND BREATHE.
LONG EXHALATION.
Ann: YOGA IS HARD
'CAUSE WE'D BE EITHER
UPSIDE DOWN OR SQUATTING AND--
JUST WEIRD STUFF.
Saavas: TRY TO CONTROL
YOUR BODY.
JUST RELAX.
Toccara: I WAS
SWEATIN' SO HARD.
I DON'T THINK
I LIKE YOGA.
Saavas: COME DOWN.
LAY DOWN
ON THE FLOOR,
FACE TOWARDS ME.
BRING YOUR CHEST
OFF THE FLOOR.
BRING YOUR HANDS
ON THE LEFT SIDE OF YOUR BODY.
Yaya: ONE OF THE MOVES
ENTAILS TURNING AROUND
AND RIGHT BEHIND ME
IS JANICE,
JUST LOOKING FABULOUS
AS ALWAYS.
Janice: IN THE MODELING
ART AND FIELD,
WE HAVE A SERIES OF POSES
WE HAVE TO DO
THAT GOES ALONG WITH
THE WHOLE LINEUP OF MODELING.
I'M NOW GOING TO TEACH YOU
HOW TO POSE.
WE'LL START WITH BATHING SUITS
WITH THE STOMACH IN.
WHOO-HOO.
WITH MY DIRECTION,
I THINK ANY MODEL
CAN BE DIRECTED
TO BECOMING
A SUPER DIVA.
WE'RE GOING TO COUNT
FOUR BATHING SUIT POSES
THAT WE CAN GO TO.
ONE, TWO,
THREE, FOUR.
NOW DO YOU SEE
MY HANDS AND MY TOES?
HERE'S MY FRIEND
THE PHOTOGRAPHER.
ARE YOU SINGLE?
Jeffrey: NO.
Janice: JUST KIDDING.
Norelle: THE PHOTOGRAPHER
IS ONLY THERE
TO TAKE
YOUR PICTURE.
EVERYTHING ELSE
IS ON YOU,
LIKE THE WAY YOU MOVE
YOUR HAIR,
THE WAY
YOU DO THIS.
Janice: YOU MUST ALWAYS
BE AWARE TO NOT
BRING THE CROTCH LIKE--
HELLO.
IMPORTANT NOT TO LOOK
LIKE A PORN STAR.
IMPORTANT TO LOOK
EDITORIAL.
SUCK IT IN,
HIKE IT UP, OWN IT.
NECK, HANDS,
FEET.
NECK, HANDS, FEET.
UNH!
STRETCH THAT CENTER
FROM THIS SIDE HERE.
STRETCH YOUR BODY.
STRETCH.
NOT THAT FAR.
COME ON,
WORK WITH ME.
WE'RE GONNA DO
A TRIPLE.
TAKE ALL THE TENSION
OUT OF YOUR FACES.
Eva: JANICE PUT
CASSIE, JENN AND ANN
IN A PHOTO TOGETHER.
Janice: THINK
LENGTH HERE.
KIND OF
JUT IT FORWARD.
SUCK IN
THE STOMACHS.
OKAY,
YOU STEP OUT.
Eva: KICKED JENN
OUT OF THE PHOTO.
JENN, YOU BETTER
WAKE UP, HONEY.
YOU'RE NOT LOOKIN'
TOO HOT.
Janice: BAM,
BORE THROUGH THE CAMERA.
FRENCH "VOGUE."
MNH.
"ELLE" MAGAZINE.
Jennipher: MAYBE I
WASN'T DOING IT RIGHT.
MAYBE SOMETHING
WASN'T THERE.
THAT'S FINE,
YOU KNOW?
IT WAS JUST
PRACTICING.
IT'S NOT LIKE IT WAS
SUCH A BIG DEAL.
Janice: NEXT WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE ANOTHER CATEGORY.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE
DIVA IN GOWNS
AND POSE
WITH GOWNS.
Nicole: JANICE WALKS IN
IN THIS GORGEOUS GOWN.
SHE JUST STARTS
MOVING IN IT
AND WORKING
THE GOWN
AND THAT WAS-- THAT'S OUR LESSON
RIGHT THERE.
Janice: OKAY.
ALL WRONG,
OKAY?
Eva: I LIKE
JANICE DICKINSON.
WHAT SHE SAYS
ISN'T SUGARCOATED.
Janice: YOU HAVE
A BIT OF A HANDICAP
BECAUSE YOU'RE SMALLER,
SO YOU NEED TO THINK LENGTH.
THERE YOU GO.
DIVA POSE,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
EVA HAS PROMISE.
SHE OWNED IT,
SHE WORKED IT.
SHE'S GOT
POTENTIAL.
TRY TO PUT SOME COUTURE FEELING
INTO THIS MARC BOUWER GOWN.
NOW I WANT YOU
TO OWN IT AND RULE IT.
THAT'S HEAVEN--
THAT'S IMPRESSING ME.
I WAS REALLY IMPRESSED
WITH NORELLE,
EVEN THOUGH SHE CAN'T
WALK IN HEELS.
SHE POSED IN THEM.
KIND OF HIKE
THE NIPPLE UP
SO THEY'RE NOT, LIKE,
BENT DOWNWARDS.
LIKE, YOU KIND OF TAKE IT UP
AND, LIKE, LEAN 'EM BACK.
YOU HAVE TO HOLD IN
YOUR STOMACH.
DIVA QUEEN!
TOCCARA NAILED
THE POSE.
SHE GOT THAT FEELING
OF DIVA.
I'M DIGGIN' THIS.
CHIN DOWN. CHIN DOWN.
CHIN DOWN.
YES!
THAT'S A POSE.
THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
YOU NAILED THAT.
AND KEEP DOING
THOSE SPINS.
BRING MOTION
TO THOSE STRINGY THINGIES.
(giggles)
STRINGY THINGIES--
HA HA HA.
YOU ARE NEXT.
THAT GOWN--
HOW DO YOU FEEL IN IT?
Jennipher: UM,
IT FEELS PRETTY GOOD.
Janice: YOU CAN DO BETTER,
EVEN IN IDAHO.
PRETEND IT'S A COW
JUST GIVING BIRTH,
LIKE IT'S THE MOST INCREDIBLE
COW GIVING BIRTH,
AND SELL ME THE GOWN
WHEN I ASK YOU.
THERE'S NO EXPRESSION
IN YOUR FACE,
AND YOU'RE NOT AWARE
OF YOUR INTENT.
WATCH YOUR MOUTH
AND WATCH YOUR EXPRESSION.
CLOSE YOUR MOUTH.
DON'T LOOK
ANGRY.
LOOK COUTURE.
ALL RIGHT,
LET'S START OVER.
'CAUSE THIS IS NOT
WORKING FOR ME.
KELLE HAS NO EXPRESSION
IN HER FACE.
IT WAS LIKE I WAS
AT THE DENTIST'S OFFICE
PULLING OUT
A TOOTH.
I COULDN'T GET
HER EXPRESSION TO CHANGE.
THEN HIDE YOUR FACE
IF YOU CAN'T DO IT, LIKE...
Kelle: AND IT WAS
JUST DISCOURAGING TO ME,
BUT, YOU KNOW,
I WAS JUST ALSO SENSITIVE
BECAUSE I HAD BEEN TAKING SUCH
HORRIBLE--HORRIBLE PICTURES,
AND,
IT'S LIKE, WELL,
MAYBE YOU'RE NOT AS CUTE
AS YOU THOUGHT YOU WERE.
Janice: THANK YOU
SO MUCH
FOR ALLOWING ME
TO BE OF SERVICE TO YOU.
Women: THANK YOU,
JANICE.
Yaya: IT'S CLAP...
Kelle: OKAY, READY?
AND CLAP...
Toccara:
NOW HOLD ON.
Kelle: (laughing)
Yaya: (laughing)
Tyra: HELLO.
Women: HEY!
Tyra: HI.
Kelle: HOW YOU DOIN'?
Tyra: COME ON.
Toccara: HOW ARE YOU?
Yaya: TYRA STOPPED IN,
WHICH WAS A PLEASANT,
PLEASANT SURPRISE.
Tyra: SO I KNOW
THIS WHOLE EXPERIENCE
IS EXTREMELY
STRESSFUL,
SO I CAME HERE
TO HAVE A ONE-ON-ONE TALK
WITH EVERY SINGLE
PERSON HERE.
KELLE,
YOU'RE FIRST.
HOW ARE YOU?
Kelle: OKAY.
Tyra: HAVE A SEAT.
DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR ANYTHING?
Kelle: YEAH,
I WANNA KNOW
WHAT SOME OF MY STRENGTHS
AND MY WEAKNESSES ARE.
Tyra: WELL, I THINK
YOUR STRENGTH IS YOUR SKIN,
AND THEN THE WEAKNESS IS
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND YOUR FACE,
'CAUSE YOU ARE
PHOTOGENIC,
BUT THE WAY YOU PLACE YOUR FACE
IN A PICTURE
MAKES YOU
NOT PHOTOGENIC.
Kelle: OKAY, BUT, TYRA,
YOU KNOW WHAT?
IT'S SO DIFFERENT
IN THE MIRROR.
Tyra: NO, KELLE, IT'S NOT
DIFFERENT IN THE MIRROR.
MNH-MNH, THAT MIRROR'S THE
PHOTO-- IT IS THE PHOTO.
Kelle: I'M TRYING NOW.
Tyra: GET THAT FIERCE
ON THAT PICTURE.
Kelle: I AM. I AM.
Tyra: SO WHAT DID YOU
THINK MODELING WAS
BEFORE YOU GOT HERE?
Ann: I KNEW
IT WAS HARD.
I JUST--I GUESS I ASSUMED--
BECAUSE I'D ALWAYS BEEN TOLD,
"OH, YOU SHOULD BE A MODEL,
YOU SHOULD BE A MODEL."--
THAT IT WOULD
NATURALLY COME TO ME.
Tyra: DO YOU KNOW WHY YOU'RE
GOOD AT EVERYTHING ELSE?
Ann: WHY?
Tyra: BECAUSE YOU STUDY IT
AND YOU PRACTICE IT.
YOU DIDN'T JUST START
DOING WATER POLO AND SAY,
"OH, A POOL.
THAT'S CUTE.
LET ME GET IN IT WITH MY BIKINI,
AND I'M GONNA WIN."
YOU WALKED INTO THIS MODELING
WORLD AND DIDN'T HAVE A CLUE.
Ann: RIGHT.
Tyra: SO WHAT'S UP, CASSIE?
HOW YOU DOIN'?
Cassie: I'M GLAD I'M HERE,
'CAUSE I DIDN'T COME HERE
SO I COULD GET AWAY
FROM WHAT I DID.
I'M NOT GOING BACK
TO STRIPPING.
Tyra: IF I HAVE ANYTHING
TO DO WITH IT,
YOU AIN'T GOIN' BACK.
I'LL BE COMIN' UP
ON THE STAGE
AND GRABBIN' YOUR LITTLE NAKED
BUTT OFF THAT STAGE AND SAYIN',
"YOU'RE COMIN' HOME
WITH ME, CASSIE.
"WE'RE NOT DOIN'
THIS ANYMORE."
Cassie: THANK YOU,
TYRA.
YOU'RE GONNA MAKE ME CRY
JUST BECAUSE YOU CARE SO MUCH.
Tyra: I DON'T NECESSARILY FEEL
LIKE YOU WANNA BE AT THE TOP
OR EVEN REALLY WANNA
BE HERE.
Jennipher: SEE, AND I DON'T KNOW
WHY PEOPLE THINK THAT.
MAYBE BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
COME ACROSS STRONG
AND I'VE ALWAYS KEPT THAT
TO MYSELF.
Tyra: IN ORDER
TO WIN THIS COMPETITION,
OR EVEN TO PROGRESS
FROM WEEK TO WEEK,
THERE'S A FIRE
THAT PEOPLE NEED TO FEEL,
AND I THINK THAT WOULD BE
MY NOTE FOR YOU--
TO LEARN HOW TO WEAR
YOUR EMOTIONS
A LITTLE BIT MORE
ON YOUR SLEEVE
BECAUSE
IT'S ENDEARING.
Jennipher: BASICALLY, TO ME,
WHAT SHE WAS SAYING IS,
IF YOUR PERSONALITY
DOESN'T COME OUT,
I WAS GOING HOME,
IS WHAT I TOOK IT.
Toccara: SOME PEOPLE ASK ME,
"WHAT IS YOUR GOAL?"
AND IT'S LIKE,
I'M HERE TO WIN
AND I'M ALSO HERE
TO BREAK BARRIERS.
I'M HERE TO BE THE FIRST
BLACK PLUS-SIZE SUPERMODEL,
SO SOME PEOPLE ARE LIKE,
"OH, NO, YOU'RE TOO BIG,"
AND EVERYBODY WAS JUST
TELLIN' ME STUFF, YOU KNOW?
Tyra: HOW DOES IT FEEL
WHEN THOSE NEGATIVE ONES
ARE SAYING THAT TO YOU?
Toccara: I'VE BEEN THROUGH SO
MUCH NEGATIVE STUFF IN MY LIFE.
I MEAN,
MY MOM DIDN'T RAISE ME,
AND MY DADDY
DIDN'T RAISE ME,
AND, UM...
WHY ARE YOU
MAKING ME CRY, TYRA?
Tyra: OKAY,
THIS IS A BEAUTIFUL PART
OF YOU,
AND THIS IS-- THIS IS GONNA
MAKE YOU A BETTER PERSON
BY BEING A HUMAN BEING
AND NOT JUST BEING
ONE-DIMENSIONAL.
Toccara: YEAH.
Tyra: IT'S TRUE.
Toccara: THAT'S WHY
I FIGURE,
MAYBE ONCE I GET
TO WHERE I WANNA GO,
MAYBE I CAN HAVE MY MOMMY,
I CAN HAVE MY DADDY,
AND THEN I JUST REALIZE THAT
I DON'T HAVE POWER.
LIKE, SHE HAS
TO WANT IT.
MY DADDY
HAS TO WANT IT.
SO IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHO I AM OR WHO I'LL BECOME.
THEY JUST HAVE TO WANT--
I CAN'T MAKE THEM
DO ANYTHING.
Tyra: BUT DO YOU
THINK MAYBE
BY YOU BEING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
OR JUST BEING SUCCESSFUL
IN ANY TYPE OF WAY HERE
WILL INSPIRE THEM
TO WANT IT?
YOU KNOW,
"LOOK WHAT SHE DID"?
Toccara: I CAN'T CRY
NO MORE.
I DON'T WANNA
CRY NO MORE.
I CAN'T GO RIGHT BACK
TO THE SAME THING--
THE SAME THING.
IT'S LIKE...
Tyra: BUT DO YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU'RE CRYIN'
THAT MEANS
IT'S STILL THERE,
AND IT'S STILL INSIDE?
Toccara: YOU KNOW,
WHY CRY ABOUT SOMETHING THAT
YOU CAN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT,
YOU KNOW?
I--AND MAYBE I'VE TOUGHENED
MYSELF UP, YOU KNOW?
BECAUSE I-I CAN'T
DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
I CAN'T DWELL
ON IT.
I CAN'T BE
STUCK ON IT.
I CAN'T LET IT
AFFECT ME.
I CAN'T--
YOU KNOW, I CAN'T.
I JUST GOTTA LET IT GO.
I CAN'T KEEP--
Tyra: NOW LOOK WHERE YOU ARE
RIGHT NOW.
YOU ARE HERE,
AND YOUR SISTER,
11 YEARS OLD,
IS RIGHT THERE
LOOKIN' AT YOU,
AND I THINK YOU HAVE
TO USE THAT AS POWER.
THAT'S WHAT'S
FUELING YOU.
THAT'S WHAT GIVES YOU
THAT BEAUTIFUL SMILE
AND THAT
BEAUTIFUL ENERGY
AND THAT'S WHAT'S
MAKING THOSE PICTURES BEAUTIFUL.
IT'S WHERE
YOU COME FROM.
COME HERE
AND SIT WITH ME.
Toccara: I CAN'T
CHANGE THEM, TYRA.
Tyra: NO,
YOU CAN'T CHANGE THEM,
BUT YOU CAN DO
FOR YOU,
AND YOU CAN DO
FOR YOUR SISTER,
AND YOU CAN BE AN INSPIRATION
FOR YOUR MOTHER.
SHE'S GONNA SEE
HER BABY
AND BE LIKE, "OH, MY GOD.
I SCREWED UP SO BAD.
"I DON'T KNOW HOW
MY BABY GOT THERE,
"BUT SHE GOT THERE."
Toccara:
(sobbing)
Tyra:
SHE GOT THERE.
Toccara: I DON'T
BELIEVE IT.
SHE MADE ME CRY.
WE WAS JUST TALKING ABOUT
MY FAMILY AND ME GROWING UP.
AND I WAS JUST...
(sighs)
I'M STILL SHOCKED AT MYSELF
THAT I CRIED.
I COULDN'T BELIEVE THAT I HAD
TEARS COMING OUT OF MY EYES.
BECAUSE, LIKE I SAID,
THIS IS JUST MY LIFE.
THIS IS JUST WHAT
I HAD TO GO THROUGH.
I HAD TO BE
SUPPORTIVE.
I HAD
TO BE STRONG.
SO I HAD TO BE THAT ONE
THAT PEOPLE COULD COME TO
AND CRY ON,
YOU KNOW?
I WANNA BE AN INSPIRATION
TO PEOPLE, YOU KNOW,
BUT THE ULTIMATE GOAL HERE
IS TO BE THE LAST ONE STANDING.
SO YOU GOTTA SURVIVE.
Kelle: (sobs)
THE PAST THREE PANELS,
I'VE HAD PROBABLY
THE WORST PHOTOS IN THE GROUP.
I'VE HAD
A PENIS.
I'VE BEEN A DEER IN HEADLIGHTS
IN THE MIDDLE OF A CEMETERY.
I'VE BEEN A PLATYPUS
THAT JUST CAME FROM A DENTIST.
THE MIRROR
IS THE CAMERA.
I WAS JUST SEEING MYSELF,
AND I'M LIKE,
"OH, MY GOD, I'M HIDEOUS."
(sobs)
Toccara: WHERE'S KELLE?
DON'T BE CRYING.
COME HERE,
MAMA.
WHAT'S WRONG?
Kelle: I CAN'T LOOK AT MYSELF
IN THE MIRROR.
Toccara: (laughs)
Kelle: I'M SO SERIOUS,
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND.
I JUST SPENT
THE LAST HOUR--
EVERYTIME I LOOK IN THE MIRROR,
I'M CRYING.
Toccara: BEFORE YOU WAS ALL
IN THE MIRROR.
YOU COULDN'T GET YOUR ASS
OUT THE MIRROR.
EVERY TIME I TURNED AROUND
YOU WAS IN THE MIRROR.
YOU WAS HERE, YOU WAS HERE,
YOU WAS THERE.
KELLE CAME
IN THIS COMPETITION,
AND SHE WAS JUST LIKE,
"OH, I'M BEAUTIFUL."
AND THE JUDGES HAVE TOTALLY
BROKE HER.
IT'S NOT
GOOD PRACTICE.
THIS IS
NOT HEALTHY.
Kelle: I CAN'T.
Toccara: COME
TO MY ROOM,
SIT ON MY BED
AND TALK TO ME.
GET OUT OF HERE,
COME ON, LET'S GO.
I SAID,
"GIRL, GET OUT THAT MIRROR.
"COME TO
MY ROOM."
Kelle: I REALIZED
WHAT IT WAS.
IT'S THIS PART OF MY MOUTH--
RIGHT HERE.
IT'S LIKE AN EXTRA LAYER
OF FAT OR SOMETHING.
SO IT'S LIKE
A SNOUT.
AND THAT'S WHY I HAVE--
LIKE, YOU SEE IT? LOOK.
LIKE, SHE HAS THAT,
TOO.
SEE, LOOK.
LOOK AT IT.
YOU SEE HOW IT'S LIKE
A SNOUT PART?
Toccara: OKAY,
BUT WHAT'S UGLY ABOUT THAT?
Kelle: I'M JUST SAYING
I DON'T-- I DIDN'T--
I WAS IN DENIAL
ABOUT MY SNOUT,
AND NOW I KNOW.
AND SO IT'S JUST HARD
TO WORK.
YOU'RE VERY LIMITED--
Toccara: WELL, OBVIOUSLY
SHE'S DOING SOMETHING,
'CAUSE BITCH
IS GETTING PAID.
Kelle: 'CAUSE SHE KNOWS--
Toccara: SO OBVIOUSLY
BITCH WORKIN' IT.
Kelle: SO THAT'S WHAT
I LOOK LIKE IN THE MAGAZINE.
Toccara: I'M GONNA KICK YOU
OUT OF MY ROOM IN A MINUTE.
Toccara: YES!
TYRA MAIL!
"DO YOU EVER
HAVE A DREAM
THAT YOU WERE WALKING AROUND
IN ONLY YOUR UNDERWEAR?"
Nicole: WE GET
OUR TYRA MAIL,
AND I'M THINKING WE HAVE TO DO
A RUNWAY SHOW IN PANTIES.
Eva: YOU THINK WE NEED
TO WEAR SEXY PANTIES?
Yaya: NO,
THEY'LL GIVE US UNDIES.
Eva: I'M GONNA BE ME.
GONNA BE WEARING
MY LUCKY LADY DRAWERS.
Amanda: EVERYBODY KNOWS
LA PERLA IS "IT" IN LINGERIE.
IT IS JUST MWAH,
BEAUTIFUL.
Simon: HI THERE.
HI.
OKAY, GIRLS,
WELCOME TO LA PERLA.
MY NAME
IS SIMON DOONAN.
I'M THE CREATIVE DIRECTOR
OF BARNEYS.
I UNDERSTAND YESTERDAY
YOU LEARNED A LOT ABOUT POSING.
AND TODAY'S CHALLENGE
IS ALL ABOUT POSING.
NOT ONLY ARE WE GONNA PUT
YOU GALS IN LINGERIE,
BUT WE'RE GONNA PUT YOU
IN THE WINDOW OF LA PERLA
IN FRONT OF THE WHOLE
NEW YORK CITY.
Women: OH, MY GOD!
Jennipher: UM, I NEVER
THOUGHT I'D BE HALF-NAKED
IN THE WINDOW
OF A STORE.
OH, GOD, YOU KNOW,
EVERYONE'S GONNA SEE MY BUTT.
Simon: YOU'VE GOTTA
LOOK ALLURING.
YOU'VE GOTTA LOOK
INTERESTING.
BUT YOU CAN'T LOOK CHEAP
AND SLUTTY.
I'M GONNA DIVIDE YOU
INTO GROUPS.
EACH GROUP IS GONNA POSE
FOR TEN MINUTES.
YOU'RE GONNA BE JUDGED ON
YOUR CREATIVITY,
YOUR STYLE
AND YOUR TECHNIQUE.
Toccara: I'M REALLY
COMFORTABLE WITH MYSELF.
SO LONG AS YOU HAVE SOMETHING
THAT FITS ME,
HEY, PUT ME OUT THERE.
Simon: THE WINNER GETS...
$5,000 WORTH OF LINGERIE.
Women: OH!
Woman: OKAY, HI.
Kelle: HI.
Woman: SO YOU ARE A...
Kelle: 34D AND A SMALL.
Woman: YOU'RE A 34D
AND A SMALL. OKAY.
AND WHAT SIZE
ARE YOU?
Eva: GOOD QUESTION.
I NEVER WEAR
A BRA.
Woman: A 32B
OR A 34A?
Eva: NOT A B.
Woman: AND WHAT SIZE
ARE YOU?
Toccara:
I'M A 38DDD.
(gong sounds)
Woman: OKAY.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
A FEW CHOICES.
YOU CAN TRY THIS ON,
TOO.
Toccara: THAT'S NOT
GONNA WORK.
Woman: LET'S SEE HOW THAT
FITS ON YOU.
Toccara: LA PERLA DIDN'T HAVE
MY SIZE BRA IN STOCK.
AND THE ROBE
WAS A MEDIUM,
BUT, YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE TO DEAL
WITH WHAT YOU'RE GIVEN.
BUT YOU DON'T
HAVE THONGS?
I HAVE TO WEAR
BIG PANTIES?
Woman: I'M GONNA SEE. OKAY?
Toccara: OKAY.
I WOULD BUY
THIS ONE.
AND I WOULD TAKE THIS ONE,
I WOULD PASTE IT,
AND THEN I WOULD PASTE THIS
OVER HERE,
AND I WOULD SEW IT
TOGETHER.
Yaya: I'M KINDA PRACTICING
WHAT POSES I MIGHT DO.
REMEMBERING THE TIPS
THAT JANICE HAD GIVEN US.
ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
FOOT UP, KNEE DOWN, TWIST,
BACK ELONGATE, BUTT OUT,
WHATEVER.
Kelle: I'M FEELING
PRETTY GOOD.
ESPECIALLY SINCE I'VE BEEN
PRACTICING A LOT IN THE MIRROR.
I HAVE, LIKE,
A NEW FOCUS POINT TODAY.
Simon: OKAY, FIRST GROUP
KELLE, NICOLE AND YAYA.
FOLLOW ME
AND LET'S GO INTO THE WINDOW.
Yaya: WE'RE
IN THE WINDOW.
THERE WERE ONLY A FEW PEOPLE
WALKING BY,
BUT THOSE FEW PEOPLE
STOPPED.
AND THEN, ALL OF A SUDDEN,
THE STREET GOT BUSIER.
Simon: COME ON,
YES!
IT'S A COMPETITION,
GIRLS.
Kelle: I'M LIKE,
"OH, MY GOD, YAYA'S DOING
ALL THIS FLEXIBLE STUFF."
AND NICOLE IS DOING LIKE,
JUST REALLY WEIRD STUFF.
AND WE'RE IN THE WINDOW
OF LIKE, LA PERLA,
WHICH IS THIS VERY HIGH-END
LINGERIE LINE.
THEY DON'T WANT TO SEE
A PIN-UP GIRL
AND A STATUE
OF LIKE, MIGHTY APHRODITE.
Simon: FABULOUS! GREAT!
LOVE IT!
KELLE JUST SEEMS
VERY NATURAL.
EVERYTHING SHE'S DOING
SEEMS EFFORTLESS.
OKAY, NEXT.
Toccara: I WAS VERY, LIKE,
STIFF-- I JUST--
Toccara: CASSIE
IS JUST WILD.
AND SHE'S JUST LIKE,
"OOH. OOH!"
I'M LIKE, "OKAY."
Simon: REMEMBER WHAT JANICE
SAID, "CLASS, NOT CRASS."
FABULOUS.
Simon: ANN IS A GIRL
WITH A LOT OF POTENTIAL.
SHE IS VERY STRONG,
VERY ELEGANT.
IT'S A NATURAL THING.
YOU CAN TELL
THAT'S WHO SHE IS.
THREE MINUTES MORE,
GIRLS.
GIVE IT ALL YOU'VE GOT.
YEAH, MORE.
JENNIPHER--
SHE'S A LITTLE DULL/
VERY DULL.
AND CUT.
OKAY, GIRLS, GOOD JOB.
AMANDA, I DON'T THINK
NECESSARILY
LINGERIE IS YOUR FORTE.
NOW, YAYA, A LOT OF IT WAS
VERY ATHLETE, VERY BODYBUILDER,
WHICH IS MAYBE GOOD
IF YOU'RE DOING NIKE.
NORELLE,
OF ALL THE GIRLS,
YOU CAME ACROSS
AS BEING THE MOST SWEET.
KELLE, I THOUGHT YOU WERE
VERY CREATIVE.
DIDN'T SEEM LIKE
IT WAS A BIG DEAL FOR YOU.
YOU ACTUALLY LOOK MORE NERVOUS
NOW THAN YOU DID IN THE WINDOW.
CASSIE, IT'S A LITTLE TOO
"BADA-BING."
THOSE GUYS OUT
IN THE STREET
WERE CRASHING THEIR CARS
INTO EACH OTHER.
NICOLE, YOU WERE KIND
OF LIKE '50s PIN-UP.
I THOUGHT
THAT WAS VERY CUTE.
TOCCARA,
YOU'RE--OBVIOUSLY YOU HAVE
A SENSE OF HUMOR,
BUT I DIDN'T SEE ANY OF IT
IN THE WINDOW.
WORK ON BRINGING
SOME OF YOUR NATURAL CHARM
INTO YOUR MODELING.
ANN, YOU WEREN'T
PARTICULARLY CREATIVE,
BUT YOU HAVE
A NATURAL ELEGANCE TO YOU.
NEVER ONCE
DID YOU LOOK SLEAZY.
EVA, YOU'RE
A REAL SHOW-OFF.
AND I LIKE THAT.
JENNIPHER,
YOU HAVE A GREAT BODY.
BUT YOU LOOKED LIKE YOU'D
HAD A QUAALUDE OR SOMETHING.
Jennipher: SOMETIMES
IF MY ENERGY'S LOW,
I JUST TRY
AS HARD AS I CAN.
TODAY I KNOW I WASN'T
GONNA BE UP TO PAR
TO BE MISS PERSONALITY,
BECAUSE I DIDN'T FEEL TOO GOOD.
Simon: THE WINNER
OF THIS CHALLENGE IS...
KELLE.
Women: WHOO!
Kelle: THIS MEANS
A LOT TO ME
BECAUSE THE JUDGES HAVE ONLY
KEPT ME AROUND
BECAUSE
THEY SAW POTENTIAL IN ME.
AND I CAN GIVE THEM
SOME REASSURANCE
THAT I DO
BELONG HERE.
Simon: YOU GET 5,000 BUCKS.
YOU HAVE TO PICK
TWO OTHER GIRLS,
AND THE FIRST ONE THAT YOU PICK
GETS 1,500 BUCKS.
THE SECOND ONE GETS 500.
Kelle: OKAY, I'M GIVING
THE 1,500 TO AMANDA.
YOU GET THE 500,
TOCCARA.
Toccara: YOU'RE FABULOUS!
Cassie: I DON'T THINK THAT
THIS GIVES KELLE AN EDGE.
SHE'S BEAUTIFUL
IN PERSON,
BUT SHE HASN'T BEEN ABLE
TO PULL IT OFF IN PICTURES YET.
Kelle: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANKS, BYE!
Women: THANKS, GIRLS.
Ann: TYRA MAIL.
"THE MODELING WORLD
IS A CATTY DOG-EAT-DOG BIZ.
"SOMETIMES YOU JUST GOTTA
ROLL WITH THE PUNCHES.
"BE READY TO LEAVE AT 7:45
IN THE MORNING."
Amanda: I WONDER IF WE'RE
GONNA HAVE,
LIKE,
A PHOTO SHOOT WITH ANIMALS.
Ann: I NEED, NO MATTER WHAT,
TO HAVE A GOOD PICTURE,
BECAUSE IF
I'M NOT CONSISTENT,
I FEAR THAT THAT WOULD CAUSE ME
TO BE ELIMINATED.
Kelle: I THINK THAT
WE ARE GOING TO BE DOG BOXING.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO FIGHT
EACH OTHER.
FIGHT SOME BITCHES.
Toccara: I'LL KNOCK
A BITCH OUT.
YOU KNOW, YOU REALLY DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT TO EXPECT.
I HAVE TO TAKE
WHATEVER IT IS,
AND I HAVE
TO BE FABULOUS.
Jennipher:
I'M STRESSED OUT.
EVERYTHING WE DO,
WE'RE BASICALLY JUDGED ON,
AND I HAVE TO GIVE 100% MORE,
YOU KNOW?
I KNOW I HAVE THAT ATTITUDE
DEEP INSIDE ME.
I JUST...
DON'T LET IT OUT.
AND EVEN THOUGH I DO WANNA WIN
NOW, NOBODY SEES THAT.
Man: Show 'em.
Jennipher: (sighs)
Norelle: SO WE GOT
THIS TYRA MAIL,
AND IT SAYS,
"ROLL WITH THE PUNCHES."
AND "IT'S A DOG-EAT-DOG WORLD"
OR SOMETHING.
WE WERE THINKING ALL KINDS
OF CRAZY STUFF.
Ann: WHAT'S IN HERE?
Nicole: WE ARRIVE
AT THE ROXY,
AND WE'RE GREETED
BY JAY MANUEL.
Jay: WE GOT A LOT
OF HAIR AND MAKEUP TODAY.
IT'S REALLY EXCITING,
SO I JUST WANNA
TAKE YOU GUYS UP THERE.
Eva: WHAT ARE WE DOING?
Jay: AND START HAIR
AND MAKEUP.
WE'RE DOING A PHOTO SHOOT,
GIRL-- WHAT DO YOU THINK?
Eva: BUT WHAT
ARE WE DOING?
Toccara: WE GET THERE,
AND JAY DOESN'T TELL US
WHAT'S GOING ON.
HE JUST SENDS US UP
TO HAIR AND MAKEUP.
Jennipher: OH, THAT'S COOL,
I LOVE IT.
Norelle: I LOOK LIKE
ONE OF THOSE DOLLS
THAT'S, LIKE,
SO PRETTY,
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT IT
AT NIGHT,
YOU'RE RUNNING
OUT OF THE ROOM SCREAMING.
I LOVED IT.
Jay: WHOA, LOOKING COOL.
CAN I BORROW ALL OF THEM
FOR, LIKE, ONE SECOND?
I JUST WANT
TO INTRODUCE THEM
TO THE PHOTOGRAPHER REAL QUICK
AND STUFF.
AS YOU CAN SEE,
THE HAIR AND MAKEUP'S REALLY FUN
AND THE CLOTHES
ARE REALLY FUN.
SO IT'S A REALLY CREATIVE,
COOL SHOOT TODAY.
KELLE JUST TOLD ME THAT YOU WON
THE POSING COMPETITION
WHICH I STILL FIND
HARD TO BELIEVE,
BUT ALL RIGHT,
WORK IT OUT, GIRL.
WE GOT A LITTLE SOMETHING ELSE
WE'RE ADDING
ON TOP
OF THE SHOOT.
Toccara: WE WERE LIKE,
"OH, GOD, HERE IT COMES."
Tyra: YO!
Women: WHOO! YAY!
Tyra: HI, EVERYBODY.
Women: HEY, TYRA.
Tyra: SO TODAY YOU GUYS
ARE DOING A PHOTO SHOOT
FOR DOONEY & BOURKE
PURSES.
AND YOU'RE GONNA BE DOING IT
ON ROLLER SKATES.
DID YOU NOTICE THE TYRA MAIL
SAID, "SOMETIMES YOU GOTTA..."
Women: ROLL
WITH THE PUNCHES.
Ann: WE THOUGHT ANIMALS
WERE GONNA BE INVOLVED
IN EVERY SHOOT,
'CAUSE WE'RE RETARDED,
AND WE READ WAY TOO MUCH
INTO TYRA MAIL.
Tyra: TODAY YOU'RE GONNA
BE PHOTOGRAPHED
BY MATTHEW JORDAN SMITH.
Matthew:
HELLO, LADIES.
Women: HELLO!
Matthew: WHAT'S
GOING ON?
Tyra: HE TOOK ALL THE MOST
AMAZING PICTURES OF ME
WHEN I STARTED,
EVEN NOW.
AND YOU'RE GONNA
MAKE 'EM FIERCE, RIGHT?
Matthew: ABSOLUTELY.
Tyra: BYE, GUYS!
Women: BYE!
Cassie: BYE, TYRA, BYE!
Matthew: BEAUTIFUL, NORELLE.
THERE WE ARE.
Norelle: IT'S FUN,
BUT I DON'T ROLLER SKATE
SO IT WAS KINDA DIFFICULT
FOR ME.
Matthew: YOU'RE
THE DOLL.
I WANNA GET ALL OF THIS,
ALL OF YOUR FACE.
NORELLE'S GOOD, BUT SHE KEPT
WONDERING ABOUT THE SKATING
VERSUS WORRYING ABOUT GIVING ME
A GREAT FACE.
Jay: SO ARE YOU
A ROLLER SKATER, YAYA?
Yaya: OH,
I'M NOT.
I WAS VERY SURPRISED
BY MY INABILITY
TO JUST SKATE
AND STOP
AND HAVE CONTROL.
Matthew: LET'S GO, YAYA.
KEEP MOVING.
NOW YOU'RE ON,
NOW YOU'RE ON.
LOVE THAT,
LOVE THAT.
Jay: THAT'S AN AD.
LIKE, THAT I CAN SEE
AS A BILLBOARD.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
YAYA SUCKED
ON THE ROLLER SKATES,
BUT HER POSES
WERE INCREDIBLE.
Mathu: OH,
YOU'RE SO DRY.
Toccara: I KNOW,
THAT'S WHAT I SAID.
I ASKED FOR SOME LOTION
OR SOMETHING.
Mathu: OH, I THOUGHT YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT
SOME KIND
OF REMOVER.
Toccara: MY BOOTY DON'T
LOOK DRY, DO IT?
PAT MY BOOTY.
Mathu: I'LL SLAP IT FOR YOU,
YOUNG LADY.
Toccara: OKAY.
AM I SUPPOSED TO--
DO YOU WANT ME TO SKATE
AROUND THE BALL OR NOT?
PUTTING ON SKATES
AND TRYING TO MODEL
IS SO DIFFICULT.
Matthew: WHOA, CAREFUL,
CAREFUL, CAREFUL,
CAREFUL.
SLOW IT DOWN.
KEEP YOUR COMPOSURE
HERE.
NO FALLING.
THERE WE ARE.
CAREFUL, CAREFUL, CAREFUL,
CAREFUL!
Toccara: I'M OKAY.
I FELL PRETTY HARD
A COUPLE TIMES,
GRACEFULLY.
Matthew: OH, OH, CAREFUL!
CAREFUL, CAREFUL,
CAREFUL!
SELL ME THAT FACE.
FORGET
ABOUT THE SKATING.
I WANT YOU TO THINK
ABOUT THIS.
Toccara: OKAY.
Matthew: YOU'RE IN
A COMPETITION.
Toccara: I KNOW.
Matthew: SHOW ME THE BEST
YOU HAVE.
TOCCARA--
SHE WAS, LIKE,
JUST CAUGHT
IN THE FUN OF IT ALL
VERSUS
GETTING THE SHOT.
OH, OH,
CHANGE IT AROUND,
GO THE OTHER WAY.
Jay: OOH, THAT ONE LOOKS LIKE
SHE'S TAKING A DUMP.
REMEMBER YOU'RE SELLING
THE BAG.
IT'S LIKE SHE FORGOT
SHE'S SELLING THE BAG.
CASSIE WAS VERY AWKWARD
WITH THE BAGS.
SHE WAS A LITTLE MEDIOCRE
FOR ME TODAY.
ARE YOU READY TO NOT FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE IN IDAHO?
WE NEED COUTURE.
WE NEED LIKE,
PARIS "VOGUE."
Matthew: THERE WE ARE.
LET'S GO.
GO BACK MORE.
MORE ENERGETIC,
MORE ENERGETIC.
Jay: WHEN YOU PUSH OFF,
YOU PUSH, YOU GO...
UGH! UGH!
AND THEN YOUR HEAD
IS UP.
Jennipher: I GOT
THE SKATING DOWN,
BUT IT'S JUST LIKE,
SO MANY THINGS YOU HAVE TO DO.
YOU HAVE TO SKATE.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE
YOUR POSITIONING RIGHT,
THE BAGS RIGHT,
YOUR FACE RIGHT.
Matthew: HAVE FUN
WITH THIS.
MODELING IS FUN.
COME ON,
I WANNA SEE THAT.
JENNIPHER--
SHE'S A BEAUTIFUL GIRL.
THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT,
BUT SHE GIVES NOTHING.
Mathu: THAT'S YOUR HAIR?
Eva: NO, THAT'S
MY STUFFING.
Mathu: YOU'RE GETTING--
Eva: I'M GETTING
A TOP HAT.
Matthew: THERE.
EVA.
OH, THAT'S NICE.
THAT'S NICE!
Jay: YOU BETTER WORK.
YOU DID
SO WELL TODAY.
Eva: THANK YOU.
Jay: THIS IS EVA'S
BEST SHOOT TO DATE.
SHE ALLOWED HERSELF
TO BECOME MORE FLUID
AND MUCH MORE BEAUTIFUL.
Nicole: I FEEL LIKE
A MARILYN MONROE
DONE BY
ANDY WARHOL.
IT'S REALLY FUN.
Matthew: OH, WHOA!
CAREFUL! CAREFUL!
Jay: I LOVE
THIS ONE.
NOW I DON'T KNOW
IF THIS IS GOOD NEWS
OR BAD NEWS.
YOU LUCKED INTO, LIKE,
THE SHOT OF THE CENTURY.
Kelle: OH! OH! OH!
Matthew: DON'T TAKE OUT
THE CREW.
Kelle: I'M SORRY.
IN THE PAST, YOU KNOW,
I HAVEN'T BEEN ONE
OF THE STRONG FORCES
IN THIS
COMPETITION.
BUT SINCE YESTERDAY AT LA PERLA
WHEN I WON,
I THOUGHT THIS WAS REALLY
MY TIME TO SHOW THEM, LIKE,
ALL THE THINGS
I'VE BEEN PRACTICING,
AND HOW FAR
I'VE COME.
Matthew: HAVE FUN WITH IT!
Jay: IT'S COOL TO TRY
WEIRD THINGS,
BUT IF IT'S
COMING OUT LIKE THIS--
AND NOT-- AND NOT EVEN LIKE
A FUNKY SOMETHING...
Kelle: OKAY.
Matthew: COME ON. COME ON.
THAT'S IT.
Jay: THAT LOOKS LIKE
MARY TYLER MOORE.
DON'T GET GHETTO
IN THE FACE, KELLE.
Matthew: THAT ONE WAS, TOO.
Kelle: IF THIS PHOTO SUCKS,
THEN I'M PRETTY MUCH GOING HOME.
BUT I GOTTA
THINK POSITIVE.
Woman: ALL RIGHT,
HERE WE GO.
WHAT DO YOU GUYS THINK?
Danilo: GIVE IT A SPIN.
I LIKE THAT.
Woman: SHE LOOKS
GORGEOUS.
Matthew: WHOA.
WHOOPS!
OH, THAT'S NICE!
BEAUTIFUL!
YOU ARE ROCKING THIS,
YOUNG LADY, ROCKING THIS!
WHOA.
(laughs)
Jay: YOU FELL THE MOST,
BUT YOU HAD THE MOST FRAMES.
LIKE, I HAVE SO MUCH TO CHOOSE
FROM OVER THERE,
IT'S KIND OF...
DAUNTING ME.
ANN TRIES
TO BECOME A MODEL.
AND WHEN SHE DOES HER MODEL
THING, SHE BECOMES--
Ann: UGLY.
Jay: WELL,
NOT LIKE A MODEL.
YOU'RE ALREADY DOING
THAT THING WITH YOUR MOUTH, ANN.
ANN,
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
Matthew: DON'T POSE
AGAIN-- REMEMBER THAT.
Jay: THERE'S
THE FACE THING.
I JUST WANNA STOP YOU
BEFORE WE GET THROUGH THE END.
AND THEN IT'S LIKE,
"IT JUST SUCKED."
Ann: RIGHT.
Jay: BUT IT--IT--
Ann: SUCKS.
Jay: SHE'S KILLING ME.
ANN, I WOULD HATE
TO SEE YOU NOT MOVE ON
IN THIS COMPETITION
AFTER THIS SHOOT.
Matthew: TAKE IT EASY,
ANN.
NICE AND EASY.
TAKE A COUPLE
DEEP BREATHS.
IT'S ALL RIGHT.
THIS IS
WORKING.
THIS IS REALLY
Jay: THAT'S HOT.
Matthew: BEAUTIFUL.
BEAUTIFUL
Jay: THAT'S
DEFINITELY HOT.
IT'S GOOD FOR HER,
TRUST ME.
Matthew: THAT'S NICE!
YES!
Jay: ANN DEFINITELY
RESPONDS TO MEAN.
LIKE, YOU'RE NICE TO HER,
AND SHE SUCKS.
Matthew: THANK YOU.
THANK YOU
Ann: SORRY
I WASN'T BETTER.
Matthew: NO,
YOU DID GREAT.
Jay: SHE AIN'T COMING
OVER HERE TO HUG ME.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU GOT BETTER
WHEN YOU RESPONDED TO NASTY.
Amanda: TYRA MAIL!
"TOMORROW YOU MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
"ONLY NINE OF YOU
WILL CONTINUE
"IN HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
Eva: SOMEONE'S GOING HOME,
GUYS.
Amanda: PEOPLE GET
ELIMINATED.
Yaya: AT NIGHT WE GET HOME,
AND THERE'S A TYRA MAIL,
AND IT'S LIKE, "OKAY, ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED."
LIKE, "YEAH, OKAY,
WE KNOW THAT. DUH."
BUT, YOU KNOW, DESPITE THE FACT
THAT WE KNOW IT'S COMING,
IT'S LIKE A WEIGHT FALLS
ON THE HOUSE.
Kelle: I'M REALLY NERVOUS
TO SEE THE PICTURES.
Amanda: YEAH.
I HOPE YOU DID WELL.
Kelle: ME TOO.
Amanda: YOU CAN'T LEAVE ME.
I WON'T HAVE A FRIEND.
I HAVE NO IDEA
WHO WILL GET ELIMINATED.
I THINK THAT UNFORTUNATELY
IT'S GONNA BE KELLE OR ANN.
Ann: WE DID STUFF TODAY
AND, LIKE, I FEEL LIKE,
IT'S JUST NOT, LIKE,
GOOD ENOUGH.
Woman: Honey, you've gone
a very, very long way.
And just to even be there
and to be one of the ten...
Relax and whatever
will be will be.
Ann: IT'S LIKE,
I FEEL LIKE I'M WASTING
SUCH A GOOD OPPORTUNITY.
Woman: Just let go
of it,
and whatever's gonna happen
is gonna happen.
Just go
with the flow.
Ann: YEAH, BUT, MOM,
THIS IS SOMETHING I WANT.
Woman: I know,
honey.
But sometimes maybe that's not
what is gonna be best for you.
Ann: I'M FEELING
FRUSTRATED
BECAUSE MY SHOOT YESTERDAY
WAS NOT WHERE IT SHOULD BE.
YOU KNOW, IF KELLE
HAS A GOOD PICTURE,
OR JENN HAS
A GOOD PICTURE,
I ASSUME THAT I MIGHT
BE LEAVING.
Kelle: IF I'M ELIMINATED,
I'LL BE DISAPPOINTED IN MYSELF.
YOU KNOW, 'CAUSE I REALLY AM
MAKING AN EFFORT.
Jennipher: WE STARTED OFF
WITH 14 GIRLS.
AND TONIGHT
IT'S GONNA BE NINE.
I'M THINKING
I MIGHT GO HOME.
I MIGHT STAY.
Toccara: I'M HAPPY.
THE MORE PEOPLE LEAVE,
THE CLOSER AND CLOSER
I COME TO MY DREAM.
I DEDICATED MY DAY
TO YOU.
AND I DID SO GOOD.
I WAS LIKE,
"THIS IS FOR MY FATHER."
I'M NOT GOING HOME.
SOMEBODY ELSE
GOTTA GO.
Tyra: HELLO, EVERYBODY.
WE ARE ONE STEP CLOSER
IN DETERMINING WHO WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
WE HAVE
SOME FABULOUS PRIZES--
A CONTRACT WITH THE TOP
INTERNATIONAL MODELING AGENCY
FORD MODELS,
A SPREAD
IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE
WHICH WILL BE PHOTOGRAPHED BY
WORLD-RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER...
Janice: GILLES BENSIMON.
Tyra: EXACTLY.
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
NOW WE HAVE
SOME VERY INTERESTING JUDGES--
MISS JANICE DICKINSON,
ONE OF THE WORLD'S FIRST
SUPERMODELS.
NIGEL BARKER,
A NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
Nigel: HELLO, LADIES.
Tyra: NOLE MARIN,
PROMINENT FASHION EDITOR
AND STYLIST.
Nolé: LADIES.
Tyra: AND, OF COURSE,
OUR SPECIAL GUEST JUDGE,
MATTHEW JORDAN SMITH.
FIRST, JANICE WILL ADMINISTER
YOUR TEST.
Janice: HERE'S THE SURPRISE
YOU'LL BE WORKING WITH.
HIS NAME IS LANNY,
OUR MALE MODEL.
Women: (laugh)
Janice: HI, LANNY.
Eva: OH, HELL, YEAH.
Janice: A PHOTOGRAPHER
WILL BE TAKING PHOTOGRAPHS
OF YOU POSING
WITH LANNY.
YOU'LL BE JUDGED
ON HOW WELL YOU POSE.
TOCCARA,
YOU'RE FIRST.
Carissa: READY
WHEN YOU ARE.
Toccara: SO, UM,
THIS IS MY CANVAS--I JUST--
(laughs)
Ann: STAND FORWARD.
JUST STAND RIGHT THERE.
AND THEN...
Norelle:
ON YOUR KNEES.
Jennipher:
OKAY, LET'S SEE.
Amanda: IT'S GETTING
KINDA CLOSE.
FORWARD.
Cassie:
LET'S DO THIS.
TURN AROUND.
Nicole: HELLO.
Kelle: CAN YOU HOLD
MY WEIGHT?
Lanny: MM-HMM.
Kelle: OKAY,
STAND STILL.
NO, YOU'RE GONNA HOLD ME.
Lanny: HOLD YOUR FOOT?
Kelle: LIKE THAT.
(whispers)
HOLD MY WEIGHT.
Tyra: WE ARE GOING TO START
WITH TOCCARA.
AND WE'RE GOING TO SEE
YOUR PHOTOS NOW.
Janice: YOU LOOKED LIKE
YOU WERE GOING TO THROW HIM
OVER YOUR SHOULDERS
LIKE A CAVEWOMAN.
Nigel: YOU NEED TO BE
MORE NATURAL, LESS DRAMATIC.
Tyra: I DISAGREE
WITH ALL OF YOU GUYS.
LOOK AT HER ARCH
OF HER BACK.
LOOK AT THE BUST.
LOOK AT
HER BODY.
IT LOOKS RETOUCHED.
HER BODY
LOOKS RETOUCHED.
I LIKE IT.
YOU DID A PHOTO SHOOT,
AND YOU WERE ON ROLLER SKATES.
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
Nolé: TOCCARA,
THERE'S NO SEX APPEAL
IN THAT SHOT AT ALL,
AND YOU ARE SO SEXY.
HERE YOU JUST LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE WAITING FOR THE BUS.
Janice: SHOULD'VE BEEN,
"I LIKE TO DISCO," YOU KNOW?
AND GOTTEN THAT FEELING
AND SWINGING THE BAG, HONEY.
Tyra: NORELLE.
Janice: OH, MY GOD.
ENGAGE
IN THE BOY.
EW!
Tyra: (laughs)
Nigel: THAT WAS SCARY.
Tyra: ROLLER SKATING
IN THE ROLLER RINK.
Nigel: YOUR EYES
AND YOUR FACE SOLD US.
Tyra: DAMN,
NORELLE'S GORGEOUS.
YOU KNOW,
SEXY.
Tyra: ALL RIGHTY,
UP NEXT WE HAVE JENNIPHER.
I THOUGHT YOU HID BEHIND HIM
AND HAD NO INTENSITY WHATSOEVER.
Janice: THIS SCARES ME.
Matthew: JENNIPHER,
OUT OF ALL THE GIRLS YESTERDAY,
I THOUGHT YOU GAVE ME
THE LEAST.
Nigel: YOU HAVE AN INCREDIBLE
FACE FOR MAKEUP.
YOUR FACE LOOKS GOOD.
Janice: WHY DO YOU WANNA BE
A MODEL?
Jennipher: WE WENT THROUGH
THIS LAST WEEK.
Janice: WHAT?
Tyra: IT DOES LOOK LIKE
YOU DON'T WANNA BE THERE.
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE JUST
"SKATING" THROUGH.
ALL RIGHTY,
UP NEXT WE HAVE EVA.
Nolé: EVA THE DIVA
NEEDS TO COME OUT.
Tyra: LANNY IS SHOWING YOU UP
ON YOUR SHOTS.
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
Nigel: IT'S NICE TO SEE YOU
PERHAPS TAKE A LITTLE RISK.
YOU KNOW, WHICH THROUGH THE HAT
COULD'VE BEEN--
Eva: THAT WAS MY HAIR.
Nigel: THAT WAS
YOUR HAIR?
Eva: YEAH.
Janice: WHY DIDN'T HE PUT
THAT HAT ON YOUR HEAD
INSTEAD OF YOUR FACE?
Eva: THAT WAS THE LOOK
HE WAS GOING FOR.
Tyra: I LIKE THE FACT
THAT YOU DID NOT BLAME HIM.
Nigel: REALLY, ME TOO.
Tyra: ALMOST DEFENDED HIM.
I LIKE IT.
NEXT WE HAVE NICOLE.
LOOKS LIKE YOU WERE AT A SCHOOL
DANCE, TAKING PICTURES.
LIKE, "HEY!"
Nigel: THAT'S KINDA COOL.
Nolé: NOW SEE I LIKE THE LEGS
IN THIS POSITION HERE.
I THINK IT'S KIND OF CUTE.
IT WORKS--
GORGEOUS.
Janice:
VERY GOOD.
Tyra: THE STRONGEST PICTURE
IN THE BUNCH.
ALL RIGHT, YAYA.
Janice: HELLO.
NAIL.
Tyra: WHEN THAT LEG
WENT UP,
CHILD, I WAS LIKE,
"WHOA. I LIKE IT."
Matthew: I WAS LOOKING
AT A DANCER SOMETIMES,
NOT A MODEL.
Tyra: HERE'S YOUR
BEST SHOT.
Janice: THIS IS
MY FAVORITE PHOTOGRAPH.
Tyra: I AGREE
WITH MATTHEW
ABOUT THE DANCER VERSUS
THE MODEL THING.
I'M SAYING INSTEAD OF...
♪ LA ♪♪
IT'S...
Yaya: I'M GLAD I DIDN'T DO
THE OTHER POSE I WAS THINKING.
Janice: THAT WOULD'VE BEEN
MESSED UP.
Tyra: NEXT WE HAVE ANN.
Nolé: ANN, I'VE TITLED YOU
MY "ORGASMIC LETDOWN."
BECAUSE WHEN I SEE YOU,
I AM SO EXCITED ABOUT YOU.
BUT EVERY TIME I SEE YOUR PHOTOS
I'M LIKE, "YES! YES!
(gasps)
"NO."
Nigel: THE BIGGEST PROBLEM
I HAVE WITH THIS PICTURE
IS NOT THAT
IT'S BAD.
IT'S JUST THAT IT'S NOT
THE BEST YOU CAN DO.
Matthew: AND JAY REALLY
GOT ON YOU FOR A REASON.
AND AFTER HE PUSHED YOU,
WE GOT THAT.
Nigel: YOU KNOW,
YOU NEED TO BE POWERFUL.
YOU NEED TO BE
EXCITING.
JUST LOOK AT THESE TWO WOMEN
ON EITHER SIDE OF ME.
BOTH OF THEM
ARE EXCITING, POWERFUL,
YOU WANNA BE
AROUND THEM.
THEY'VE GOT
THAT ENERGY.
YOU NEED
TO HAVE THAT.
Tyra: I'VE SEEN YOU.
YOU KNOW,
I'VE SEEN THIS POWERFUL GIRL.
PUT IT THERE.
Nigel: YEAH.
Tyra: NEXT
WE HAVE AMANDA.
I FEEL FIRE PULSING
THROUGH THE VEINS HERE.
Janice: IT'S THE BEST
POSE YET.
Tyra: HERE'S
YOUR BEST SHOT.
Nigel: OH,
I LOVE IT.
Janice: THAT'S
FABULOUS.
Tyra: WAIT TILL YOU SEE
THE CLOSEUP.
Matthew: AMANDA,
THIS IS MY FAVORITE PICTURE
IN THE BUNCH.
Tyra: CASSIE.
IT'S SAFE.
Nolé: VERY SAFE.
Tyra: I PUT
"SEXY, GOOD, SAFE."
ROLLING ON SKATES--
Nolé: YOU LOOK
KIND OF EMPTY.
THERE'S NO FEELING.
YOU'RE NOT
IN THERE.
Matthew: WHEN YOU GO
ON A JOB,
YOU'VE GOT TO BE "ON"
ALL THE TIME.
Tyra: KELLE.
Nigel: YOU WERE VERY BOSSY
WITH THAT MALE MODEL.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU DID
INTIMIDATE HIM,
AND THE FUNNY THING IS,
THESE ARE HIS WORST PICTURES.
Nolé: BUT AT LEAST
YOU WERE THE ONLY GIRL
THAT TRIED TO DO SOMETHING
AS EXOTIC AS THIS.
UM, THOUGH AS YOU CAN SEE,
IT DIDN'T REALLY WORK.
Kelle: YEAH.
Tyra: HERE IS
YOUR BEST SHOT.
Janice: YOUR NECK
LOOKS LIKE A QUARTERBACK.
JUST ALL WRONG!
Tyra: I THINK YOUR FACE
IS PRETTY.
THIS WAS THE BEST
OF THE WORST.
Janice: IT'S THE SAME FACE
IN EACH PHOTOGRAPH.
Tyra: ANN.
Janice: SHE'S SO
BEAUTIFUL.
Nolé: BUT IN A PHOTO?
SHE'S BASICALLY
A BIG LOSER.
Tyra: THIS IS
A PRETTY PICTURE.
BUT PRETTY DON'T MAKE YOU BUY
DOONEY & BOURKE PURSES.
NORELLE.
Nigel: SHE LOOKS DYNAMITE.
Janice: THIS IS
HER ONLY LOOK.
Tyra: YAYA.
Janice: THIS PHOTOGRAPH
JUST ROCKS.
Nigel: BUT FOR ME, IT'S STILL
TOO DANCER, DANCER, DANCER.
Tyra: CASSIE.
Matthew: COLD FISH.
Nolé: I FIND HER
HOT AS HELL.
Tyra: SHE'S SELLABLE.
SHE'S VERY
SELLABLE.
TOCCARA.
Matthew: SHE FILLS UP
THE ROOM WITH HER ENERGY,
BUT THEN ON FILM,
IT'S DEAD.
Janice: SHE'S
GOTTA GO.
Tyra: SO YOU'RE GONNA THROW
SOMEBODY AWAY
BECAUSE THEY HAVE
ONE BAD SHOT?
Janice: YES.
Tyra: EVA.
Nolé: EVA HAS ONE OF
THE MOST INCREDIBLE FACES HERE.
Tyra: SHE DEFINITELY HAS
A STAR POWER IN PERSON.
IN PICTURES EVA'S GOOD,
BUT EVA'S NOT GREAT.
Janice: EXACTLY.
Tyra: NICOLE.
Nigel: NICOLE LOOKS FANTASTIC
IN THIS PICTURE.
Matthew: SHE HAS A TWINKLE
IN HER EYE.
Tyra: JENNIPHER.
Nigel: OH,
JENNIPHER.
MY GOODNESS, ME.
Nolé: GREAT
BONE STRUCTURE.
Matthew: JENNIPHER
IS A PRETTY FACE.
BUT IT STARTS
AND STOPS THERE.
Janice: SHE'S NOT THE WORST
OF THE LOT.
Tyra: AMANDA.
Nolé: BY FAR
HAS STOLEN MY HEART.
Janice: THIS PHOTOGRAPH
IS CLEARLY THE BEST PHOTOGRAPH.
Tyra: KELLE.
Nigel: SHE GIVES THE SAME
LOOK OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
Nolé: SHE LOOKS LIKE
J. ALEXANDER IN THIS PICTURE
AND I LOVE J.
Tyra: I THINK
THIS IS THE BEST PHOTO
KELLE HAS
EVER TAKEN.
I'M GRADING KELLE
AGAINST HERSELF.
NOW IF I GRADE KELLE
AGAINST THE OTHER GIRLS,
SHE FAILS.
Janice: WELL,
THERE YOU HAVE IT-- DUH.
Tyra: TEN GIRLS
STAND BEFORE ME.
BUT I ONLY HAVE NINE PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE NINE OF YOU
THAT WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
AMANDA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
YAYA.
NORELLE.
EVA.
NICOLE.
TOCCARA.
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU WERE
OVER THERE GIVING UP.
YOUR EYES ARE SO DEAD
IN YOUR PICTURES, TOCCARA.
THAT EXTRA SOMETHING
NEEDS TO COME OUT OF THEM.
CONGRATULATIONS.
FOUR GIRLS LEFT.
THREE PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
Tyra: ANN.
ANN,
THIS PHOTO?
IT'S NOT HORRIBLE.
IT'S
SATISFACTORY.
NO TOP MODEL
IS "SATISFACTORY."
CONGRATULATIONS.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
IS CASSIE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Cassie: THANK YOU.
Tyra: WILL JENNIPHER
AND KELLE PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS.
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I WILL CALL
ONLY ONE NAME.
AND THE NAME
THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY PACK YOUR
BELONGINGS AND LEAVE.
JENNIPHER,
FROM WEEK TO WEEK
IT SEEMS LIKE YOU DON'T WANT
TO BE HERE.
AND AS MUCH AS
YOU CRY TO THE JUDGES,
AS MUCH AS YOU SAY IT,
WE DON'T FEEL IT.
KELLE,
YOUR PICTURES HAVE BEEN
LITERALLY
SOME OF THE WORST
IN THE BUNCH.
SOME OF THE JUDGES WONDER
WHY YOU'RE STILL HERE.
AND WHEN THEY LOOK AT YOU,
THEY SEE A MODEL.
WHEN THEY LOOK AT YOUR PICTURES,
THEY DO NOT SEE A MODEL.
Tyra: KELLE,
MAYBE THERE IS SOME POTENTIAL
LOCKED IN THERE SOMEWHERE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Kelle: THANK YOU.
Tyra: YOU'RE WELCOME.
THANKS,
JENNIPHER.
Jennipher: THANKS.
Jennipher: IF I DIDN'T
WANNA BE HERE,
I WOULDN'T HAVE LEFT EVERYTHING
I HAD BACK HOME TO COME HERE.
I'M A REAL
INDEPENDENT PERSON.
I COULD DO THINGS
ON MY OWN,
DO THINGS
BY MYSELF.
EVENTUALLY,
IT WILL HAPPEN.
I FEEL THAT
THIS IS MY PURPOSE,
BUT IT'S JUST NOT
AT THIS TIME.
Tyra:
STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
Tyra: COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"--
CASSIE FESSES UP
ABOUT HER DARK SECRET.
Cassie: I HAVE HAD
SEVERAL TIMES WHERE
I'VE THROWN UP
IN THE PAST.
Tyra: KELLE LOCKS HORNS
WITH JAY MANUEL.
Kelle: I DON'T DEAL WELL
WITH LIKE,
"YEAH, YOU'RE
DOING GREAT!"
'CAUSE I'M NOT REALLY
DOING GREAT.
Jay: BUT, YOU KNOW,
AT THE SAME TIME, KELLE,
I CAN'T BABY YOU
THROUGH EVERY FRAME.
Tyra: AND A PRACTICAL JOKE
TURNS UGLY.
Ann: I DO HAVE
A SENSE OF HUMOR.
I THOUGHT MAYBE CASSIE
HAD ONE, TOO.
Cassie: DON'T TOUCH MY...